this video is kindly sponsored by wren
hey 42 here
the 2nd of september 1859
was one of the strangest days in all of
human history
it started like a scene from a sci-fi
horror film when compasses all over the
world began to go haywire spinning and
whirling as though north was suddenly
everywhere all at once
at about the same time bright lights
appeared in the night sky so bright that
people in europe and north america got
out of bed and started getting ready for
work despite the fact sunrise was still
hours away
just in case everyone wasn't already
freaked out enough before long the
global electrical telegraph network the
cutting edge communications tech of the
day
failed suddenly and completely
and when i say failed i don't mean it
shut down no it went absolutely mental
telegraph wires started throwing off
sparks setting pylons on fire and
generally scaring the crap out of
everyone nearby
and telegraph operators received
powerful electric shocks whenever they
tried to go near their equipment
panicked technicians disconnected the
batteries powering telegraph stations in
an attempt to put a stop to whatever the
hell was going on
but it didn't work
despite having no visible supply of
electricity the telegraph network kept
on functioning just fine for hours on
end
have you ever felt that little bit of
climate change guilt for perhaps not
doing enough well
ren is an awesome website where you can
not only calculate your carbon footprint
but actually offset it
by answering a few quick questions about
your lifestyle like i did you can find
out your carbon footprint and how you
can reduce it now obviously no one can
reduce their carbon footprint to
absolute zero therefore with ren you can
effortlessly offset your remaining
carbon footprint
by contributing a small amount based on
your answers to help fund one of their
fantastic projects
you'll receive monthly updates from the
tree planting rainforest protection and
other green projects you're helping to
support free rent
you actually get to see the trees you
planted and what your money is spent on
and the best place to start is by
heading over to ren dot co and learning
more about your carbon footprint also
i've partnered with ren to plant 10
extra trees for the first 100 people who
sign up using my referral link in the
description below
perhaps unsurprisingly considering the
somewhat biblical vibe of these events a
fair few people thought the end times
were upon them what else could turn the
night sky today and magically power
electrical devices outside of a hungover
deity who'd had one too many ambrosius
the night before
but
when neither jesus christ nor his evil
twin the antichrist showed up to explain
what the hell was going on
people were forced to come up with other
more scientific theories
could these strange events be the result
of some kind of extreme weather
perhaps meteorites were to blame
volcanic activity maybe
gremlins leprechauns godzilla ultimately
nobody had a clue
or at least almost nobody because there
was one man who thought he had a pretty
good idea
what had triggered all this madness
his name was richard carrington an
amateur astronomer who
around 18 hours earlier had witnessed
something very strange indeed you see
carrington was interested in sunspots
and while studying a particularly large
cluster of them from his own personal
observatory in surrey
he'd seen two balls of intensely bright
white light erupt from the sun's surface
at the time carrington had no idea what
had caused the flashes but when the
entire world went stark raving mad in
the early hours of the following morning
he was convinced it was no coincidence
as it happened
he was right
because richard carrington had just
become the first man in history to
witness a solar flare
an intense burst of radiation emitted by
the sun
and this wasn't just any solar flare
carrington had stumbled across a whopper
today
162 years later it remains the single
most powerful solar flare ever observed
by man
these days we know solar flares are
pretty common in times of high sun
activity we might expect to see several
every day so why did the one carrington
saw cause so much chaos
well the flare itself wasn't responsible
for convincing people the world was
ending
that was down to the accompanying
coronal mass ejection a colossal cloud
containing billions of tons of highly
energetic highly magnetized plasma fired
out from the sun at speeds of up to 1800
miles per second
that's about one percent of the speed of
light or 4 000 times faster than a
speeding bullet
yeah
if you value the integrity of your cells
you really don't want to get in the way
of one of these things
luckily coronal mass ejections can be
fired off from the sun in any direction
meaning most of the time these giant
clouds of plasmary death
simply pass biles
even when they do hit the earth many are
harmlessly deflected
but
under the right conditions a coronal
mass ejection can crash into earth's
magnesphere
with frightening force
creating what's known as a geomagnetic
storm
and it was one such storm that caused
all the strange goings on experienced by
richard carrington and co
back in 1859
solar storm-induced disturbances in the
earth's magnetic field were behind the
odd behavior of compass needles and
those bright lights in the night sky
were auroras which are caused when
charged particles fired out from the sun
excite atoms in the atmosphere
as you're probably aware auroras are
pretty common near the earth's poles
but during the geomagnetic storm of 1859
known today as the carrington event
incredibly bright and widespread auroras
were seen almost at the equator
but as interesting as spinning compass
needles and dazzling auroras are
what's especially interesting about the
carrington event today is the effect it
had on the telegraph network
as magnetized plasma from a coronal mass
ejection smashes into the magnetosphere
the earth's magnetic field quivers and
compresses
sending huge amounts of electrical and
magnetic energy through the atmosphere
down at the surface all that energy can
induce huge electrical currents
seemingly out of thin air
it was this phenomenon known as a
geomagnetically induced current that
allowed the telegraph network to
function even after technicians had
disconnected it from its power source
during the carrington event
that's kind of amazing when you think
about it for a while the global
telegraph network was essentially being
powered by electrified air thanks to an
event that happened on the sun
93 million miles away
[Music]
but as well as being really amazing it's
also really really bad as you've
probably noticed the world's changed a
little bit since 1859.
back then the electrical telegraph
network was the only large-scale
electrical infrastructure on earth it
was also basically brand new having only
been rolled out in the previous decade
when it went haywire it was fairly
inconvenient but not exactly a global
crisis
fast forward to today and pretty much
our entire way of life relies on
electricity which means that if a solar
storm of the magnitude of the carrington
event were to happen today
we'd be
admittedly it's hard to say just how
badly we simply don't have the data to
accurately quantify the impact of an
apocalypse-scale solar superstorm
but it's no exaggeration to say that in
the absolute worst case scenario a
sufficiently large geomagnetic storm
could quite literally spell the end of
the modern world
as we know it
satellite communications and global gps
will be disrupted whilst additional drag
caused by heating of the earth's upper
atmosphere could see some satellites
come crashing down to earth after being
knocked out of orbit entirely
any astronauts unlucky enough to be
outside of the earth's magnetosphere and
beyond the confines of their spaceship
on a spacewalk for example
would be blasted with enough radiation
to cause serious sickness and probably
instant death
down here on terra firma things wouldn't
be much better either colossal
geomagnetically induced currents would
begin coursing through all those lovely
wires we humans like to leave lying
around everywhere eventually making
their way into key infrastructure within
the electrical grid and wreaking
absolute havoc
an earthbound coronal mass ejection in
the spring of 1989 triggered a
geomagnetic storm severe enough to cause
widespread power failures in quebec
technicians responded to the storm
fairly quickly
but six million people were still left
without electricity for nine hours and
some towns didn't even get their power
back for days that might not sound too
bad a nine-hour blackout in one region
of a single country
isn't exactly what you'd call
apocalyptic
but the 1989 geomagnetic storm was an
absolute tiddler compared to the
carrington event
if a solar storm of that magnitude were
to strike today
damage to the electrical grid might be
so severe
that tens of millions of people would be
left without power for weeks
months
or possibly even years
another key facet of modern life that
could be in trouble during a large solar
storm is the 21st century's most
widespread religion
the internet
that's because it relies on certain key
data routes collectively known as the
backbone of the internet that are
particularly vulnerable to
geomagnetically induced currents
as you've probably noticed as well as
providing a fertile breeding ground for
hilarious cat videos
the internet basically runs the entire
world these days
it's central to the safe flow of power
and water into our homes businesses and
hospitals
it keeps oil running through continent
spanning pipelines it underpins the
banking sector makes card payments
possible and ensures that global supply
chains put enough food in our
supermarkets in short widespread and
prolonged disruption to the internet
would be an utter catastrophe
when the coveted 19 pandemic began
making planet earth a significantly
worse place to live early last year
entire industries ground to a halt
key supply chains threatened to crumble
and perfectly normal people turned into
rabid toilet paper hoarding maniacs to
get an idea of what a worst case
scenario carrington event-sized
geomagnetic storm might look like
try imagining something a bit like that
only the power's gone there's no water
coming out of the taps satellites are
falling out of the sky the supermarket
shelves are completely empty
there's no fuel in the petrol stations
and
most devastatingly of all
you can't update your facebook status
oh and just to make things even more
exciting solar storms can also
effectively
jam military early warning systems
potentially giving any ambitious and
opportunistic world leader the perfect
opportunity to kick off world war iii
with a handy head start
in 1979 a particularly spicy solar storm
almost led to nuclear war
when all three of the u.s air force's
ballistic missile detection systems
suddenly jammed
this being the cold war the us naturally
assumed the soviets were behind the
attack
and since the obvious motivation for
jamming a missile detection system is to
fire a missile the us military scrambled
nuclear warhead-equipped fighter jets in
preparation for all-out war it was only
when some helpful scientists connected
the situation to the ongoing solar storm
that disaster was averted
okay so this all sounds terrible but
there is at least some good news as i've
said this is all very much a worst case
scenario some scientists are convinced
even a carrington event scale solar
storm would only inflict temporary
damage on earth's key electrical
infrastructure
even more encouragingly major
governments around the world are already
taking this threat very seriously and
steps are being taken to ensure we're
well prepared for whatever the sun can
throw at us
the less good news
sometimes known by its nickname bad news
is that we might not have much longer to
get ready ourselves
because
an apocalyptic solar storm might just be
around the corner estimates as to the
likelihood of a carrington class solar
storm occurring in any given decade
vary but
at the high end
it could be as much as 12
if that figure's accurate
most of you watching this video
will have a 50 50 chance of finding out
how this story ends within your lifetime
so be sure to let me know how it goes
and thanks for watching
good news you can now pre-order my new
book bread and circuses what did the
romans ever do for us
it's a wild and witty journey for a
thousand years of unexpected roman
history
told in a refreshing way and packed full
of incredible and unbelievable stories
copies are selling out fast so pre-order
yours today to lock it in thank you